today it's about the economy coronavirus
has a dramatic impact on our economy
most sectors are hit I know the toll
that this takes on you the lock down of
our public life is necessary to contain
the virus but it also slows down
severely our economy last week I said we
will do whatever is necessary to support
the Europeans and the European economy
today I'm happy to say we delivered the
state aid rules that we have in place
since yesterday are the most flexible
ever this will help your companies and
your jobs your governments can now give
money to the many companies that are hit
by the sudden shock hotels restaurants
transport companies small firms that
risk closing down without support today
and this is new and never done before we
trigger the general escape clause that
means national governments can pump into
the economy as much as they need we are
relaxing the budgetary rules to enable
them to do that in addition let me
welcome the decisive action announced by
the European Central Bank this week this
adds to the firepower that we need in
Europe to prop up the economy the
European budget will play its part 37
billion euros will be available to
support the healthcare sector companies
and keep people in employment and we
will do more to support you and your
families through this crisis